hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about biological hierarchy that is the
hierarchical system of structures that
makes up all of life and you can see
that it includes multiple levels moving
from the level of atoms all the way down
to the bias here we're going to go
through each one of these more
specifically but as we do I want you to
think about an important concept and
that is that each one of these levels
has emerging properties that is
properties that are specific to each
level that were not present at the level
above it and these emergent properties
are due to interactions so if these
interactions that are critical for life
for example at the most basic level we
have the atom so atoms even themselves
are made of smaller particles being the
protons neutrons and electrons that make
up atoms so atoms like hydrogen like
lithium like carbon these are the atoms
that interact there's that word again
that interact to result in molecules and
the molecules like here we have water
this is sodium chloride or table salt
they have specific properties that are
inherent to these molecules that are
made possible because of the atoms that
make the molecules up that is the
important characteristics of water
things like its solubility its ability
to more hydrogen bonds it's polarity
these are all a result of the
interactions between the oxygen atom and
the hydrogen atom then molecules can
interact together to form macro
skills for example things like DNA or
RNA which is not pictured here
phospholipids proteins carbohydrates and
even these macromolecules are also made
of smaller units DNA and RNA are made of
nucleotides phospholipids are made of a
polar head group and nonpolar fatty acid
tails proteins are made of amino acids
and carbohydrates are made of sugars so
you can see the way that these things
interact the way the way those smaller
monomers made it these different
molecules interact to allow these
different biological macromolecules to
have function now some lists talking
about biological hierarchy jump from
macromolecules to cells others include
organelles as a separate level in the
biological hierarchy of course we know
that cells are made of organelles things
like the nucleus the endoplasmic
reticulum lysosomes peroxisomes Golgi
mitochondria chloroplasts ribosomes etc
and so all of those organelles made of
macromolecules are going to come
together to allow cells to function and
again it is the interaction of things
like DNA and proteins and phospholipids
that allow these emergent properties to
exist in that cells have functions that
the macromolecules are organelles
themselves aren't able to carry out
outside of that cellular environment
now some lists also have tissues which
are groups of cells as an additional
level in the biological hierarchy others
jumped straight from cells to organ of
course organs are made up of tissues
organs themselves can be classified into
organ systems meaning that you have
tissues that interact to make organs
functional you have organs that interact
to make organ systems
channel for example here we have a
simplified drawing of the digestive
system which is made up of multiple
organs
you've got the esophagus the stomach the
small intestine and the large intestine
so these are different organs that are
interacting to allow organ systems to
carry out their functions which are a
greater function overall than the
individual organs the organ systems come
together to make organisms for example
here we can say that a lion is an
organism the lion is made up of multiple
organ systems that allow the lion to
survive a population would be a group of
organisms of the same type for example a
group of lions otherwise known as a
pride of lions would be a population a
community is when you have multiple
populations of different types of
organisms for example lions and zebras
and if we keep with this theme of
African savanna animals an ecosystem
will be made up of lions zebras and all
other populations that are present as
well as the environment so the ecosystem
is when you've got all of the organisms
interacting with their environment some
lists then include this additional level
in the biological hierarchy biomes which
are collections of ecosystems and
finally the very greatest level of the
biological hierarchy the one that
encompasses everything else is the
biosphere and the biosphere refers to
all life on our planet and so you can
see again that with the biological
hierarchy it is about increasing
complexity as you move through the
hierarchy each level acquiring new
function and ability due to specific
interaction
pree present at the previous level so
that is biological hierarchy simplified
I hope you learned a lot and thanks for
watching biology professor